foreign
[Music]
my name is sadika Watson and um so
that's me
um I uh work as a data scientist at Eli
Lilly the pharmaceutical company
I'm on the development team for a shiny
application that is used at Lily so
essentially my job is to wear this hat
the app developer hat
and this isn't just a normal shiny app
this is a complex production grade app
we get a new version of the app released
every month with new features and Bug
fixes and a lot of people in my
organization visit this app every day so
it's really important that the app is
functioning properly all the time so
with that in mind I'd like to begin with
a story about something that happened to
me back in May 2021 so I was in my home
office working on a new feature for the
app
but of course I was multitasking because
I was also keeping an eye on the
activity in our team chat window so one
of the uh users was saying she was
having some issues with the app it
wasn't populating the drop down menu
with the values that she was expecting
so the values were in the app before and
then all of a sudden she didn't see them
anymore
so one of the other developers
identified the issue and determined that
we would have to quickly release a new
version of the app that resolves the
issue with the drop down menu and that's
when I panicked because I realized that
meant two things were about to happen
first it meant oh first it meant that I
would have to put on another hat
uh my code reviewer hat so as a code
reviewer I'm responsible for reviewing
GitHub pull requests I have to read the
code to make sure it adheres to our
coding standards
um and then I have to run the app in a
local environment to make sure that all
the old features work with the new
features
I have to check the radio buttons the
drop down menus the contents of the
tables I have to make sure that the
database API in in the model API
connections are still working as they
used to right as we added these new
features and so if it passes those tests
then we deploy the app to the test
server
but then that means I have to put on yet
another hat right this time I have to
put on my app tester hat so as a member
of the app testing team I was one of
several people that had to manually
deploy the deploy the the deploy I had
to manually test the deployed version of
the app so I would have to open the app
in a web browser and then run a lot of
the same tests as before check the radio
buttons check the drop down menus check
the you know API connections database
connections all those other things that
I did before in the code review
um and so now the only difference is
that this is on the deployed version of
the app as opposed to the pre-deployment
version
now testing is very important it does
allow us to catch bugs so that we can
fix them before the new version of the
app is is released to production however
as one of the people that had to you
know who was responsible for actually
running the test I could say that this
was a really extremely tedious painful
um experience for me it was very
stressful
um I also felt undervalued right because
I'm thinking okay I have a PhD in
statistics and yet my job now is to
click this radio button right and or
check this drop down menu so I felt like
this wasn't a good use of my time
another issue is that I and the other
app testers had other priorities so we
weren't full-time app testers we could
only run the tests when we had time to
squeeze testing in and that meant that
managing all of those testing those
schedules across the different testers
meant that it could take a long time for
us to get through those tests and
actually go to the next stage of our
software release
so because uh so that was that was uh
increasing the amount of time it took us
to deploy the app
because it was so time intensive we had
to sparingly apply these tests so we
couldn't afford to run them as new
features were coming in we had to or use
multiple scenarios we can only do them
really once you know if if we could do
that and then lastly we found that
different testers were running the tests
with different conditions slightly
different conditions so there was some
subjective assessment with whether or
not the tests passed or failed so one
tester could say it passed and another
person running the same test would say
that it failed so that was a problem
so because these releases were such a
heavy burden for me I started looking
for a way to make this process more
efficient for me and for our team I was
already familiar with selenium I knew it
was a great tool for automating
interactions with the web browser and I
figured this might help automatically
check whether the UI elements were still
working on the deployed version of the
app I was somewhat familiar with the
rvest package and that it was great for
web scraping so I figured this might
help to programmatically extract the
contents of the web page and I could run
some sanity checks against it to make
sure everything's rendering properly so
selenium and Arvest could work together
on the deployed version of the app
my colleague Eric nant uh recommended
that I use the shiny test package to
test the code that other other
developers were submitting in their pull
requests
um so he figured that that might help to
automate
um some of the code reviews
um and then of course later I found out
that there was a another version of the
Chinese test package called shiny test
two that somebody will speak about later
and then finally the shiny test
documentation was recommending that we
also use the test that package and so
now I had all these tools there was a
bit of a learning curve but I took about
three months of my time and eventually
over the next three months I was able to
use those tools to create an automated
testing pipeline
let's see how the software release
workflow changed after introducing these
tools so in the code review stage in
blue we see the manual pre-deployment
testing during code reviews was replaced
with the shiny Test 2 script that
automates these same tasks and now the
code reviewer had sits on the head of
the bot that runs the test script
and then in Orange in the post
deployment testing stage I'm running the
manual test
um the the manual regression test I'm
replacing those with the suite of of
selenium test groups and then I get to
remove that heavy app tester hat from my
head and place it on the bot who was
happy to run those test script at least
he doesn't complain about it if he does
not feel happy about it
so those two changes had a significant
impact on our software release workflow
our code reviewers and app testers had
less work to do they weren't feeling
stressed out with each new release we
didn't have to worry about testers
balancing their testing duties with
other high priority work so we ended up
shortening our time to deployment from
five days to five hours which was pretty
pretty huge for our testing team uh we
could apply our testing criteria as
often as needed so no matter how many
releases we had during the month or a
feature um feature a pull requests that
we merged during the month and then
because the test logic was contained in
the test script that meant we could
consistently apply those uh that test
logic from one test to uh one from one
test run to the next so that removed
that variation in test results that we
were
so I've talked about this before on the
previous slides but here's where I get
to formally introduce the automated
testing pipeline that I'm proposing it
contains four key principles first I
believe you should automate the tests
right you should actually have some sort
of programmatic representation of your
test logic
um and this could obviously be you know
we could easily full an hour or maybe a
day talking about this but lots of
different things like you know how do
you recover safely from errors how do
you appropriately log the test results
how do you have this repository of all
your test artifacts maybe your
screenshots or things that were
downloaded in the course of running the
app you know those are that's what I
mean by automating the test or all of
that next it's important to have one or
more development servers
um that are completely separate from
your production server and that allows
us to see how the updated app works
without breaking the production version
that end users are interacting with and
then the next two principles have to do
with when we would run the test the
first is that I recommend running the a
test running some pre-deployment tests
so that you can integrate these features
safely you know in a safe space on your
development server without crashing the
version of your app that the end users
are using and then finally
um I would recommend running the the
post deployment
um check on also on the development
server and this is where we can more
closely mimic what the end users are
going to experience when they log into
the app using the web browser so again
pre-deployment and post deployment
that's that's really important
one question that comes up is whether
automation makes sense for a particular
use case or a particular web app and to
answer this question I I usually
um uh follow up with a couple follow-up
questions the first would be is the
logic consistent
um the test logic is a consistent
um you know from one run to the next so
if you can say your your step one step
two step three if you can actually have
all that logic
um and not have to worry about the
changes from one to the next
um that's one consideration and then the
second question would be
um whether the test logic can be
completely scripted so that you can get
the result with having to use any sort
of subjective judgment or having some
sort of human involved making that
decision there are other considerations
obviously so there's do you have the
infrastructure to support these
automation tools like shiny Test 2 or
selenium
um do you have time to do this right
there's a little bit of a learning curve
and a little bit of time investment in
terms of writing these test scripts but
in general I would say if you answered
yes to both of those questions then I
would say your app is a prime candidate
for automation
um
so I prepared a working example that you
can play around with on your own it's a
simple app that allows you to create an
ice cream recipe using various
ingredients like peanuts and raisins and
chocolate syrup and for the adventurers
if you want to add some chicken nuggets
to your ice cream no judgment here but
we allow you to do that so the GitHub
repo the GitHub repo linked at the
bottom has all the code needed to run
the app it also has the shiny Test 2 and
the selenium code that will allow you to
just kind of play around with this in
your own environment so I definitely
encourage you to check it out
I created a couple screencasts that
demonstrate how this would work so first
I'll show you the pre-deployment testing
with shiny test 2.
now if you're running the shiny test
script in the rstudio IDE Applause this
first you'll see that there's a run test
button visible at the top of the script
and if you click that you'll see um that
there's some activity happening over
here in the build tab that shows the
progress of the test run
this test script automatically opens up
this local version of the app in a web
browser window so I didn't do that it
did it on its own in Google Chrome and
then you'll notice that it's selecting
various check boxes and entering text
and the text field and doing all kinds
of things and showing how the app is
changing
so all of those things happened
automatically and so when I go back to
the our studio IDE I see that the test
result folder now contains a few files
that were saved in the test run and if I
click on one of those I've got
um some screenshots that show you know
what would the app look like at various
points in the app there's also this Json
file that shows the values of various
elements in the UI as they were at the
time that the snapshot was created if
you stick around for the next talk in
this session you'll actually get a
chance to see the package author of you
know the shiny Test 2 uh developer give
a presentation about shiny test two so
um I didn't spend a whole lot of time
thinking about that for this
presentation but I highly recommend that
you check that out and now finally I'll
show you what the post deployment
version of the testing looked like with
selenium
so as before we click the run test
button at the top uh we will also see
the test run progress in the build tab
in the upper right corner now before we
would actually open up automatically
this web browser in Google Chrome but
this is a headless browser so we don't
actually have access to that browser
instead it's just going to do it under
the hood and silently execute those Test
instructions that I provided
um and so we'll just see the
we'll see the mouse that I can't anymore
for some reason
where are you mouth
I see it on your side but not my side
for some reason
[Music]
okay there we go okay I'll pause that
here
um so uh what you saw and unfortunately
I wasn't able to uh to narrate that
while it was going while I was looking
for my Mouse
um was that um it was uh showing you
um how it was actually uh
programmatically running the script and
then it captured some screenshots along
the way as it progressed through the
various test scripts and it also in the
log area it let you know what was going
on in the app so it at this point it was
selecting the flavor and another point
it was selecting the the recipe uh name
and and so on
um so this was all um very easy and
straightforward thanks to the tools that
you know some of the other developers
have created um so I thank him for that
so in closing I like to re-emphasize
that these tools really make automated
testing more accessible to the general
population of data scientists especially
people like me who don't have any formal
uh training in software engineering or
software testing right we're kind of
expected to know a lot and do a lot
about a lot of different areas but this
this makes that uh that a lot easier for
us to do
um and then another thing that is out of
scope for this talk but I get asked this
all the time when I give a presentation
about automated testing
um you know how does this fit into the
CI CD pipeline you know it definitely
does and there's lots of tools that you
can use to do that in particular for
example if you had GitHub actions you
could
um programmatically run so as a person
submits their pull request you could
programmatically run your your tests on
the the pre-deployment version of the
app merge the pull request deploy to the
next test server and then actually
programmatically run that next
um set of scripts right so you can do a
lot of these things man uh very very
easy
so I'd like to thank my colleagues at
Eli Lilly in the design Hub Data
Insights information and digital
Solutions and statistical Innovation
Center uh themes for their help and I'd
also like to thank Wardell PCAT at PCAT
Studios for his help with the graphic
design in my presentation and here's my
contact information feel free to reach
out if you'd like to discuss anything
and I thank you for your time
foreign
[Music]